[Music]
hey you guys welcome back to tomes of
terror my little book review series
so if you've been watching these for any
amount of time you will probably
remember
that i had read and reviewed a couple of
novels by anya alborn before
uh those two being the devil crept in
from 2017
and if you see her from 2019 which i
think was actually the first book that i
actually reviewed for this whole series
uh now if you remember i actually really
enjoyed both of those books you know
enjoyed them enough that i wanted to
read another one of hers when it pops up
in my kindle unlimited recommendations
now if you're unfamiliar with anya
alborn she's quite a popular and also
award-nominated uh author a horror
writer who was she was actually born in
poland but she went to college in the
united states in new mexico and now
lives there in new mexico and she
actually first came to the attention of
horror readers the horror community when
her self-published uh debut novel which
is called seed became the number one
best-selling horror novel on amazon and
was subsequently optioned for film by
amazon studios back in 2012 that's when
the book came out i don't think they've
made the film yet or if they're still
planning to i think actually it was kind
of a big deal at the time because it was
the first
original novel if i'm not mistaken um
the first original novel that amazon
studios had optioned but like i said i
don't know if they've actually made the
movie yet it doesn't appear that they
have so the book i'm talking about today
is called the shuttering and that came
out in 2013
and it is every bit as well written uh
fast-paced and as entertaining as the
other two books of hers that i've read
and what this one is is essentially just
like a very simple very straightforward
people trapped in an isolated cabin
getting terrorized by creatures from the
woods type of story so if you like those
kind of just you know again very
straightforward kind of stories then
you'll probably like this one as well um
you know it's very gruesome uh like it
has like a lot of gore a lot of people
getting torn apart and eaten and things
like that um there also is a lot of
character drama
that
you know i think i don't know it's i'll
kind of get into that a little bit
because i think that was kind of a
sticking point with some people that
didn't love the book but i think it made
for me it made like the deaths that do
happen in the book like a lot more
impactful um so if you like stuff like
that then you will probably really dig
this as well now at the beginning of the
story there's kind of this prologue like
a short little chapter or whatever in
which there's like an older guy i think
he's like retired retirement age like 65
or whatever and he lives in this remote
mountain cabin with his wife and he's
out gathering wood and ends up falling
victim to
essentially like a pack of these
horrifying looking monsters who just
tear him limb from limb and eat him
so right from the very beginning we know
there's something out there in the woods
and periodically throughout the main
plot of the book you kind of get these
interspersed scenes of other characters
that we don't really know
um you know kind of cannon fodder type
of characters who are getting attacked
and devoured by these creatures so in
that way the novel is structured a lot
like a horror movie
where we occasionally kind of like cut
away from the main action to remind the
reader that the threat is like getting
closer and the core characters really
don't know what's going on so it kind of
like ups the suspense so after that
we're introduced to most of our kind of
main protagonists
now these are a set of very close-knit
twins whose names are jane and ryan and
then we also have jane's best friend
whose name is lauren and ryan's very
good girl a very heroic husky named oona
spoiler alert
the dog does die
but thankfully it's implied rather than
graphically described so
it's it didn't bother i mean it bothered
me obviously but i was like well at
least she didn't like
roll around because you guys know how i
feel about like
killing like cute animals in books so
it's like i know you have to do it
sometimes to like up the horror but it's
like you don't have to like
wallow in it you know what i mean so i'm
glad it didn't do that so this gang here
is driving up to
jane and ryan's parents cabin which is
essentially more of this big lavish like
mountain chateau mansion type situation
and it's up in the mountains of colorado
and what they're doing is they're
getting together there's one last
get-together before like all of these
big changes happen like in a bunch of
their lives so jane is a second grade
teacher i think it's second grade yeah
um who is actually like i mean obviously
the twins are from a very wealthy family
i'm a family that can afford this big
mansion out in the you know for a second
home or whatever so she's actually kind
of always been a little bit embarrassed
about the wealth of that her family and
she doesn't really like to take money
from them it's like sometimes she'll
take money from her brother like if she
really needs it for rent or some [ __ ]
but she is very much you know i kind of
want to make my own way and i don't
really want to lean on them for anything
um now she has just divorced her husband
alex who cheated on her and she's kind
of trying to put her life back together
they weren't married that long i think
it was only like four years or something
like that
now ryan her twin brother is this very
like
stereotype stereotypically handsome very
charming very confident um he's kind of
like i guess a winter sports celebrity
type guy he made a fortune writing and
reviewing like ski slopes i think like
around the world like he has a really
popular uh website and he has like all
these corporate sponsorships and he's
just like rolling in loot um and he's
like i said he's kind of famous like in
certain circles and he's got this big
deal and he's going to be moving to
zurich in switzerland uh shortly so he
kind of wants to reconnect with all his
friends and family because it's kind of
going to be their last big weekend
together and he's going to be leaving
the country also uh unbeknownst to jane
because ryan hasn't told her
ryan has actually sold this family cabin
now he and jane spent a lot of time
growing up there as children like every
season they would go up there and she
really loved it uh we never actually do
get to meet jayne and ryan's parents uh
but neither twin really has much good to
say about them particularly their dad
apparently the dad like cheated on their
mom like all the time and lately has
been sort of gallivanting around the
globe with his much younger model
girlfriend who's like an italian or
something and hasn't really talked to
them or you know made any contact with
them or anything like that and you know
they're a little bit bitter about it
ryan especially now also invited up to
this kind of last hurrah which i think
is going to be like a four-day weekend
is sawyer now sawyer is ryan's best
friend since they were all teenagers and
also jane's first love and she's never
really gotten over him
she hasn't seen him in a few years i
think she's like she invited him to her
wedding but like he didn't show up and
so she doesn't really know like where
she stands on the situation and she's
kind of apprehensive about spending time
around him again uh though she's pretty
sure she can keep it together she's been
kind of like thinking about it her
brother keeps going are you all right
with this you know i wouldn't i i can
tell him not to come if you're gonna be
weird and she's like no no it's fine
now she doesn't know it's gonna be
difficult
especially since uh at the last minute
sawyer decided that he was going to
bring his girlfriend april who none of
the other people have met before
one of the reasons that jane brought her
best friend lauren in fact was to kind
of serve as a sort of like security
blanket like in case she couldn't handle
seeing sawyer with another woman
oh and she also brought lauren i mean
she brought her because she's her best
friend too but i mean she also had some
like ulterior motives i guess like not
in a not in a nefarious way but you know
what i mean but she also brought lauren
because she thought that her commitment
phobic brother ryan would be really into
her and she thinks it's about time
because ryan's kind of one of those
playboy type you know oh i don't really
want to get married i don't really want
a commitment it's like you know he dates
all these beautiful girls but he can't
really he's kind of like afraid of
commitment so she's like well it's about
time he like settled down with a nice
girl or whatever and he and she thinks
that her that him and lauren will get
along so that was kind of like another
motivation for her bringing lauren too
ryan it should be noted also had some
little sneaky purposes of his own uh
inviting sawyer in the hopes that jane
and sawyer would get back together but
then kind of having those hopes dashed
when sorry was like oh by the way i'm
bringing april this girl that none of
you guys know even though all of them
have been friends for a really long time
i realized that when i kind of say it
out all out loud like that like when i
laid it all out it does kind of sound
like a reality show
but as i mentioned there is a lot of
drama like going on with the characters
but i thought personally that it lent a
lot of depth to the story and kind of
upped the stakes substantially because
the people going through the horror seem
like actual people and not like
cardboard cutouts but i did read a
handful of reviews that sort of lamented
that oh i couldn't connect with these
characters or i don't like them all that
much so your mileage may totally vary on
that
some of the characters are more likeable
than others but they did all seem like
kind of regular flawed mostly relatable
people albeit largely people with way
more money than i'll ever see in my
entire lifetime so there is there that
but they're not like jerks or anything
well i mean some of them are kind of
jerks but not like
to the point where they're unlikable at
least in my opinion so when sawyer and
april arrive uh they're a little bit
late because they got lost it's even
more awkward than anyone really
anticipated um though everybody kind of
tries to make the best of it at least at
first april turns out to be this kind of
sour goth chick who isn't really into
snowboarding which they all kind of came
out there to do
and doesn't really like the yuppies that
her boyfriend used to hang with uh not
gonna lie can kind of sympathize with
that situation uh also she pretty much
immediately twigs on to the fact that
jane is still into sawyer her boyfriend
and that sawyer maybe kind of uh returns
those feelings so as a result she
doesn't really make much effort to try
to ingratiate herself with the others
and comes off like pretty surly and a
little bit passive aggressive to the
rest of them she does get more
sympathetic as the story goes on but at
first you're kind of seeing her through
the eyes of everyone else and they
really don't like her very much at all
for various different reasons so while
all of this drama is going on little
things start happening like out in the
woods some of them hear kind of strange
noises out there in the middle of the
night and see the trees shuddering hence
the title
uh at first they kind of attribute this
to you know maybe it's wolves or maybe
it's elk or something like that it is
kind of like out in the middle of the
colorado wilderness after all um the
forest is full of animals um oona the
dog though uh seems really uneasy she's
kind of like scared to go outside and at
one point she even like snaps at jane
which she's never done before and every
now and then like one of the group will
kind of see like a shadow moving around
like behind the trees or just outside
the windows that looks too big to be an
elk or a wolf then a bit later on uh the
gang find this big smear of what appears
to be blood in the snow not too far from
the cabin now they don't see a body like
you know not a human body or an animal
body or anything so they assume oh maybe
it was just roadkill or it was a
predator that dragged off a deer or
something like that
uh but even more ominously april who
actually when they went snowboarding she
was like [ __ ] this [ __ ] and like stayed
in the lodge uh she overheard like a
couple of guys talking about us you know
talking about like the search and rescue
who had found a dead guy up there like
last season so all these little things
are going on and meanwhile we as the
reader uh know that the monsters are out
there because every now and then we
witness some hapless skiers or some tow
truck drivers or something like that get
eviscerated by these same monsters now
the origins of the monsters themselves
are never really explained all that
heavily which i think was probably a
good idea
but they don't appear to be supernatural
in any way i guess they kind of have
maybe a slight resemblance to a wendigo
but it's not really there's no like
mythology or folklore or anything like
that about them um because like i said
it's kind of like from these people's
point of view and they don't know what
the animals are um the animals are kind
of like described they're very very tall
and they're very very thin like
emaciated looking they have really long
spindly limbs they can climb they can
run they're really fast they have like
really really big huge teeth like these
creepy like black eyes and they're
really really super strong and they're
also like really cunning really
intelligent and they seem to have
something of like kind of maybe a social
structure or like some kind of hierarchy
within their pack like they're pack
hunters it's implied that they've always
lived in the woods here but have only
recently started attacking humans
because other food sources have maybe
become scarce so they're kind of like
coming out because maybe they're
starving but like i said they're not
they're not described as like
supernatural in any way even though
they're clearly monsters so the main
characters at the fancy cabin don't
actually even see the monsters full on
until about two-thirds of the way into
the story um although like i said you
have seen other people like around the
area like getting picked off one by one
like as the monsters kind of get closer
to the cabin
so there's been like a horrible blizzard
which snows the gang in
and at the same time sawyer and april
have this really terrible argument after
april confronts sawyer about the obvious
torch that he's still carrying for jane
um you know which like i said she's kind
of a dick about it but she's not wrong
you know what i mean so she gets real
emotional she's
really really mad really furious so she
insists look you know me and soy are
leaving but there's a blizzard and the
jeep gets stuck in a snow bank at which
point april uh who's just all together
through with all of this [ __ ] and
doesn't like any of these people and
wish she hadn't come
kind of stomps off into the storm which
obligates you know some of the gang to
go off looking for her at which point
the monster attack sort of begins in
earnest and they get their first like
good look at it so the final third of
the book is just this real tense like
nail-biting kind of survival epic um you
know characters get killed
characters get like horribly wounded the
power goes out like the food stores
start running low because they didn't
have a [ __ ] ton of food there to start
with uh and the remaining holdouts kind
of have to figure out a way to get off
this sort of like snow choked mountain
and back to civilization like before
they all become essentially monster chow
so if you're a fan of like real grizzly
kind of fairly uncomplicated monster
stories that are sort of like set in
isolated in the dead of winter at a
remote cabin in the woods then this
should be right up your alley though
keep in mind that there is a great deal
of character building and interpersonal
drama so how you feel about that will
likely impact uh your overall enjoyment
of the book as a whole i actually found
all the character interactions and all
of the turmoil and stuff pretty
compelling
and it did make the story a lot more
poignant for me um as i got like
genuinely upset when some of the
characters died just because you know i
had spent so much time inside their
heads and like knew what their kind of
like future hopes and dreams were and
what their anxieties were and now like
none of this stuff is ever going to come
to fruition because like an animal was
hungry and just like wanted to eat them
and stuff like that um again though your
mileage may vary other than that caveat
about you know there is a lot of
interpersonal drama in it i would re i
would absolutely recommend this to
anybody who is into like gory creature
features or survival horror or cabin in
the woods type stories this is a really
good one like i said it's very well
written it's very action-packed and
fast-paced it's got a lot of gore
although most of the gore is toward the
end but you know and there is like a lot
of character depth in it as well so i
quite enjoyed it and i will probably be
reading some more of anya all-born stuff
because this is the third book of hers
that i've read and i've actually uh
liked them all so that will do it for
this tomes of terror i will see you guys
on the next one bye